okay let's take our next call at six one
seven eight three zero forty seven fifty
the next caller is our caller from the
507 area code caller from 507 can you
hear me
who's this yeah yeah I can hear you
David great who's uh this is Craig so
recently I saw that the first GOP member
in Congress is in favor of the
congressional review act so how do you
think that what are the chances now on
it succeeding or being something that
hey Craig is are you watching TV while
you're talking there's something going
on in the background it's a little hard
for me to hear you yourself I'm sorry
supporting the Congressional review Act
there's a lot of people around era Craig
can you hear me okay Craig yeah yeah I
can hear you can you hear me
I can hear you so the question was that
there's a Republican who's supportive of
the Congressional review Act vote on
reinstating net neutrality is that what
you were saying yeah and I was wondering
how you think the success that that
would be now with I still think the
success rate will be zero I think that
even if it's not even every Democrat
says they're going to vote for it and
even if they did they still need a you
know a couple Republicans and even if
they do that the house is not going to
pass it and even if they did the
president's going to veto it right I
mean am I missing Pat yeah it was it did
you say senator very important um I'm
not certain I I knew I would need to
look more into it okay because the vote
is in the Senate all right it's the the
connection is um if there's something
unusual about the connection let's let's
put it that way but I would have to look
into and learn more about that